bienvenue dans paf
au menu on va parler évidemment de
football avec la crise de la fifa on
parlera aussi de la réforme de
l'enseignement au parlera de politique
et du parti socialiste est aussi de
culture avec l'exposition anish kapoor à
versailles et pour en parler stéphane
manceau professeur à l'université de
versailles-saint-quentin florence père
qu'à des gens quatrième avocate au
barreau de versailles
mustapha larbaoui président à vie du on
espère la trappe
on est bien d'accord migros marc massion
j'ai confiance ça va sephora la manie de
l'université de paris 50 de paris
versailles saint quentin les côtés côté
étudiants et jean charles lajoie dix
éditeurs ont joué des éditions la joie
d'y nager tout
alors ouais je dis des gros points à
commencer par par cette exposition qui
qui a commencé dimanche à versailles
l'expression indices cap ou alors ça
vient après d'autres après jeff koons a
fait un prêt murakami notamment après
veilhan alors il ya des expressions
d'ailleurs qui sont plus ou moins
critique et que d'autres celles qui
avaient été critiqués c'était celle de
jeff koons y sommes que l'exposition
d'un disque à pour commence à faire
l'objet de beaucoup de critiques on
parle notamment d'un des ses créations
qu'on surnomme le vagin de la reine
évidemment ça choque à versailles
qu'est ce que vous en pensez est-ce que
versailles d'abord elle donne lieu ou
pas de l'art contemporain jean samajwadi
leur ont en règle générale l'art
contemporain c'est toujours une face et
pas toujours bien mais c'est toujours
une bonne idée et c'est très bien à
versailles pourquoi pas après il ya des
choses qui peuvent effectivement ce
qu'est par exemple j'adore jef cous se
trouve très bien je comprends très bien
qu'on aime pas mais en même temps tout
en appréciant beaucoup j'ai cru se
comprenait très bien que beaucoup de
gens soient choqués qui a eu marre dans
la chambre du roi un gigantesque homards
en plastique et c'est vrai que quand un
japonais qui vient du bout du monde pour
visiter le château de versailles il
vient pas pour voir le homard jeff koons
à la place de louis xiv
donc voilà c'est de temps en temps
quelques il est venu pour ça aussi qui a
découvert versailles à côté non non je
compare donc c'est ce qui me gêne un
petit peu c'est de temps en temps on va
trop loin alors que qu'on est content
qu'on installe jeff koons très bien à
muscat pour l'art monumental c'est bien
après comme tous les artistes il un peu
provocateur parce que je veux dire ça
ressemble quand même plus un cor de
chasse qu un vagin et soir oui mais fin
mai mais lui mais lui même
maintenant je joue beaucoup là dessus
assure bien oui c'est le vagin de la
reine bon voilà c'est un peu de provoc
pour lancer le truc
après je veux dire dans deux mois il
sera retiré
c'est pas très grave et on comprenait
pas ce qu'est une mobilisation très
forte quand même un certain qu'il sait
ce qu'on a le on ne doit pas faire ça
reste et femmes
moi je vais enfin je suis plutôt
enthousiaste mais moi à tout point de
vue
alors que ce soit mes goûts pas cet
autre chose mais je trouve que cette ce
contraste entre l'art contemporain et
puis le classicisme quand même dre jose
padilla convenu pas un traître être
établi de versailles chance un choc un
choc très fécond et puis que ça fasse
parler c'est très bien pour versailles
et puis je trouve je pense vous regardez
l'histoire
enfin sans avoir une vue exhaustive et
mémé à chaque fois l'art a toujours plus
ou moins toujours choqué que ce soit en
musique que ce soit les affiches avec
sedan ça c'était l'art contemporain au
temps de louis xiv est bien suivie en
temps vous enfin avoir une littérature
enfin donc c'est bien de choquer quand
ça reste quand ça reste le fait de la
moi je trouve c'est le seul problème de
pardon de l'art monumental c'est que vit
la taille de temps en temps on a
tendance à peu à perdre le côté soin
esthétique c'est purement art et
artistique en se laissant juste a
impressionné par par le gigantisme et
hamish capot avancé jusqu'à penser quand
même c'est quand même un très bel
artiste
oui mais c'est un artiste très connu du
nord mais il fait des trucs à l'effet
d'être au grand palais je serais tenté
d'en vendre malaise mais voilà est-ce
que c'est vraiment artis est ce que
c'est un évènement ou de la revoilà de
la limite sur l'harmonie quand sonne
comme considère comme un artiste je dire
que la subversion dans l'aria rien de
nouveau elle a beaucoup qui sont
étranglés du temps de gustave courbet
avec la wii là c'est la cci soit le
contraste avec le lieu extrêmement
intéressant
stéphane a dit tout ce que je voulais
dire donc je ne rajouterai rien mais sur
le côté subversif en tant que tel quand
même bien l'origine du monde a quand
même énormément choqué la fontaine du
chance à choquer même si je sais bien
que sa seule région des 50 en détresse à
ruitz on est très très loin de l'origine
du monde la seule chose c'est le titre
le vagin de la reine c'est le coupé 407
surnom mais l'oreille d'acier c'est
devenu un jardin avec les mêmes leur bon
début mais il leur dit de faire ça mais
c'est pas lui qui l'avait trouvé
d'accord mais c'est ça qui choque me
principalement parce que sinon on est
très très loin de l'origine du monde
oui j'aime beaucoup ce que dit jean
charles à l'exception près que c'est la
seule chose qui me gêne c'est que omar
soit là mais on s'attrape qui a versé
par un rebut dans les chambres ce qui
choque
plaisanterie mise à part non mais c'est
vrai que la seule chose moi que
j'apprécierai c'est que ça soit
effectivement au moins pour le coup
éphémère et que les japonaises soient
obligés de choisir leur semaine en
fonction d'eux des événements parce que
après tout si vous voir le château et
classicisme qui vient de cette semaine
sinon tu comprends que du japon déportés
leur semaine ça serait compliqué là
encore une fois moi ça me choque
absolument pas au contraire
et je ne suis pas allé je pense que
j'irai d'abord ce que j'ai mon frangin
qui y bossent il ya longtemps que je
n'ai pas vu donc j'en profite c'est par
marc s'est jamais quitté
moi on m'a dit qu'à cette émission c'est
le cas c'est jeter le kbe proximité donc
oui bien sûr j'irai je pense que c'est
aussi fait pour s'attaquer à un moment
donné ça me provenance à mettre les gens
est ce que je ne vois pas de voir mais
ce qui m'a ce qui me passait sans fin
qui m'intéresse surtout c'est que
finalement il y à il ya un conservateur
à versailles
il ya quelqu'un qui gère ce lieu il a
jugé utile de le faire je rends hommage
à ce personnage et pour le coup gérer
vérifier si ça valait le coup ou pas
mais quelque part ça m'incite à les voir
également par sam incite aussi à bouger
voir que la culture a du sens j'ai pas
trop de jugement pour tout dire ces voix
reste s'est dit qu'on vous pensez que ça
permet aussi de voir différemment les
classicisme de la construction du
château desjardins oui je pense que
c'est complémentaire comme disait
stéphane l'art contemporain est un bon
complément au classicisme
effectivement le public est d'habitude
va voir strictement du classicisme peut
s'ouvrir de cette façon là à l'art
contemporain et vice versa donc même si
je suis pas spécialement séduite par
anish kapoor je pense que le contraste
est intéressant souvenons nous mais la
chose est un peu différente parce que ce
sont des structures permanentes mais des
discussions suscité par les colonnes de
buren dans la cour du palais royal et de
la pyramide du louvre sous la pyramide
du louvre elle est devenue précis enfin
les colonnes de buren personnes avaient
appelé ça le sexe d'henri iv
non mais ça a été contesté pendant rue
la bataille dans le dessus sur le
paternalisme tiennent peut-être de buren
pas cette dimension c'est que je leur ai
donc vous irez plus tôt ce miroir
c'est jeanine de ma part si tu me
regardes puisqu'on parle d'art est ce qu
on peut juste dire un mot du scandale
absolu du ton du ton des arbres alors il
des arts avec les cadenas allure
l'enlever qu'ils aient virer les cannas
c'était plutôt une bonne idée quand je
vois les horreurs qu'ils ont bien la
place mais jeudi à des tags mais juste
d'un ridicule mais c'est sa lune une
image de paris et de la ville de paris
de cesser goûts culturels alors là je
terrain c'est terrifiant qui reste on va
faire on va faire fondre les recycle je
sais pas mais moi c'est bercy que les
restrictions mais sur le fond c'est
horrible enfin je veux dire et des
photos de la scène mais c'est à vomir
maintenant c'est juste pour venir une
seconde sur l'exposition d'un disque à
pau alors c'est un des responsables de
verre cinquième année qui est une chose
qui gêne quand c'est qu'il ya une
culture qui est dans la perspective qui
bloque la perspective c'est le vagin de
la reine
c'est un grosse culture et là n est pas
la volée ou moins puisqu'on parle de
culture on va continuer sur ce sujet
avec évidemment et les collectivités
locales territoriales sont se heurte à
des problèmes budgétaires importants est
il l'une des matières qui est en baisse
dans les budgets c'est la culture on
regarde le sujet peut on en parle tout
de suite après
conseil communautaire mouvementée ce
jeudi soir une séance perturbée par un
collectif d'associations de citoyens et
d'élus de gauche qui s'est constitué
pour dire non aux coupes budgétaires
décidées par la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines des décisions
prises tout récemment et qui sonne le
glas pour plusieurs structures comme la
maison de la poésie à guyancourt qui va
fermer ses portes
je ressens un mélange de colère de
tristesse
et puis le dégoût en faire une des rares
maison de la poésie en france qui est le
siège de la fédération européenne des
maisons de poésie c'est pas rien il ya
quand même chaque année 3500 personnes
qui participent aux activités de la
poésie que la maison de la poésie y
compris avec le conseil général des
yvelines le conseil maintenant
départementale
et oui il ya treize ans que ça existe
pourquoi ça va bouger d'un seul coup
bang s'immisçant faire des économies on
fait moins
c'est toujours pareil quand ce jour là
la culture à moyen comme un sport à
culture et après anthony roux à magny
les hameaux la maison de l'environnement
va également fermer tout a été caché
jusqu'au dernier moment en nous mettant
totalement de côté quand je dis nous
c'est les élus de quatre des sept
communes quand même alors on nous projet
on nous promet que la maison de
l'environnement
la thématique de l'environnement va être
aux prises dans les différentes
médiathèques de dire aujourd'hui qui
connaît un projet là dessus personne du
côté de la majorité on évoque des
économies à faire et une volonté de se
recentrer sur les principales missions
de l'agglomération les actions de poésie
et de sciences seront reprises par le
réseau des médiathèques
aujourd'hui l'état se désengage on doit
trouver pour cette année on a dû trouver
5 millions 4 on n'est pas là pour
sacrifier quelque chose
au contraire on essaie de garder ce qui
est de la compétence de
l'intercommunalité et non pas venir
abonder des programmes sur des communes
que chacun s'assume
il ya des équipements qui ont été voulus
à un moment donné par les équipes
précédentes mais qui n'ont pas trouvé
leur public
quand elle n'est pas nous dire que la
maison de l'environnement est une
réussite en fréquentation
si les sujets abordés oui le sujet
scientifique
oui donc c'est pour ça que nous
souhaitons le garder et le réintroduire
aujourd'hui dans le réseau des
médiathèques pour que tout le monde
puisse en profiter
la maison de la poésie c'est pareil
tenir bon c'est un bien grand nom pour
3000 visites
outre la maison de la poésie est celle
de l'environnement les salles
culturelles connaissent également une
baisse des dotations versées par la
casse qui ces deux cas de la merise et
du grenier à sel qui perdent 170000
euros
l'année prochaine on nous annonce une
diminution supplémentaire de -33% ce qui
fait c'est notre budget artistique de la
saison entière et donc c'est la
fermeture annoncée de la merise du
grenier à sel
le collectif d'associations sera reçu
dans quelques jours par les élus
majoritaires une pétition circule la
première pétition qui a circulé c'est
celle sur la maison de la poésie qui a
déjà récolté plus de 2500
signature et la dernière signature
pétition sur demandant la réunion avec
le maire a reçu en l'espace de quatre
jours plus de mille signatures
donc on est assez confiant maintenant il
reste tout reste à faire et à bâtir les
dates de fermeture de la maison de la
poésie et de l'environnement ne sont pas
encore connues cela pourrait intervenir
à la rentrée
autre changement le musée de la ville va
intégrer la médiathèque du canal à
montigny une fois les travaux de
rénovation terminée
le collectif nouvellement créée et
promet d'autres actions à venir
voilà on a vu michel logis le président
de macasty qui dit voilà il faut trouver
5 millions un peu plus de 5 millions de
route donc des ballets mesures sont
prêtes 30% de coupes dans les budgets de
la culture femto fermeture de la maison
de la poésie une idée de la maison de
l'environnement notamment
ça vous choque moi ça me choque alors ça
me choque la même scène choc il faut
savoir modérer ses propos non la maison
la fermeture de la maison de la poésie
la maison de l'environnement
très sincèrement je sais pas exactement
quel était leur fréquentation je sais
pas exactement quel était leur action
pour la paix il y avait une donnée
historique c'était que rolande ado était
le premier président de l'acca ski qu'il
était poète
oui apparemment si la fondation pensent
que la paix ont repris bien par de lui
là dessus j'ai rien à dire je sais pas
trop de quoi il retourne maintenant la
baisse des subventions de 30% à 50% l'an
prochain et à terme complètement dans
trois ans ça c'est dramatique pour les
villes de l'agglomération mais les
conséquences sont différentes suivant
les villes
vous prenez une ville comme montini une
ville qui tourne bien avec une
population qui a relativement les moyens
de parer pour l'ensemble de sa famille à
la culture cia pas les subventions de
l'agglomération qui gère très bien dans
ce cas l'impact n'est n'est pas très
important est moins grave on va dire
vous prenez des villes qui ont des
problématiques tout autre ou là les
subventions permettent à la population
d'avoir recours aux associations
sportives de pouvoir bénéficier des
associations culturelles si vous
supprimez toutes ces subventions là les
conséquences sont dramatiques
je pense effectivement que les gens ne
se rendent pas compte de l'impact que
vont avoir ces baisses de dotations pour
les enfants
oui c'est mustapha larfaoui là c'est
grave parce que ça vous a tapé
concernera même si le football c'est la
culture maintenant c'est justement ce
qui n'est pas dit dans le reportage donc
je tiens à le préciser c'est que c'est
pas simplement la culture qui est
touchée par les 30% c'est la culture et
le sport donc l'association que je
préside le club de foot de train va
prendre moins 30 % cette année et à
terme les allocations de la dotation
pardon de la casse qui va finir 1 0 donc
c'est pas simplement la culture mais
c'est également le sport au niveau de la
casse qui ça c'est le premier point
ensuite je rejoins bien évidemment ce
que dit ce que dit sephora va c'est
qu'en fait c'est ni plus ni moins qu'une
mesure comptable mais comptable en ce
sens où on fait moins 30 trop attendait
moins trois vraie question c'est est-ce
qu'il ya pas trop technique mans amiens
pas trop de lieux culturels bien c'est
probablement vers des écoles 2020 si je
suis bien sûr sans porter atteinte
constitue social justement patrice c'est
là où finalement je suis d'accord avec
sephora et je rejoins ce que vous dites
c'est que ma ce qui me gêne c'est que
c'est une mesure purement comptable avec
un chiffre moins 30 et à terme
l'option de compétences qui élevé parce
qu'en fait c'est ça le sujet il ya une
compétence de la casse qui des comités
d'agglomération et ce n'est pas une
compétence de la castille que de donner
des subventions à la culture ou aux
sports c'est une option
cette option élevées aujourd'hui et
probablement qu'on aurait pu faire
autrement le site sur pareil c'est une
question de politique et ils ont décidé
de lever l'option et non pas de faire
finalement ce que dit sephora ou ce que
vous dites c'est à dire regardant ce qui
marche et ce qui marche moins regardant
ce qui éventuellement sur lequel on peut
faire peut-être même 50 % d'économies
tout de suite sans toucher à des choses
qui marchent
voilà je plaide également pour ma
paroisse le fait de savoir que le club
de foot de trappes mais toutes ces
subventions à leurs prêts dans
l'éducatif pour d'autres communes met ce
même argent dans des mercenaires qui
viennent pour élever le niveau
j'en veux dire en façade mais qui ne
profite pas ni à l'éducatif ni à des
joueurs de foot des communes mais qui
vont simplement alimenter des gens qui
prennent de l'argent pour faire monter
le niveau
bien que c'est pas 2 politique identique
et pourtant on va supprimer la même
chose à tout le monde donc je pense
qu'il y aura un peu plus de discernement
votre club
mais votre un peu bavard enfin je
l'espère mais je vais je vais perdre
moins 30% cette année moins 50% pour
arriver à terme 1 0 de subventions de la
caisse qui s'éclaire et je sais combien
là mais je suis mais je suis pas le seul
encore une fois je parle de la combien
vous avez actuellement on a vu 23000
vous souvenez ici autour de cette table
avait sous les regards albert on était
passé à 7000 euros
c'est 7000 euros ont passé à zéro dans
les essais les 7000 dans l'es21 de 23
ans est passé à 7
alors pour des raisons totalement
différentes mais c'est facile de 7 à
cette nuit là boyd et la ville vous
donne là c'est autre chose c'est une
compétence de la commune
effectivement le sport et la plus grosse
subvention et politique de la ville
c'est sur un budget de quoi parce que
cette maison par la caisse qui n'a mais
c'est bayonne mais ça veut rien dire
7000 comme ça sept films et séries 7000
ça veut rien dire
7000 euros le budget du club et combien
le budget du club totalement ses 230
méreau voilà donc cette nuit le rôle
alors ça mais un bâton classes étaient
10%
julia est cédé pour sa part s'était même
problème chambre je pense qu'on est
enregistrée j'ai pas parlé de périls du
club
j'ai simplement que de ce que j'entends
c'est effectivement important de savoir
que c'est à la fois la culture et le
sport c'est juste une information
complémentaire que jeunes et que pour ma
part on a passé 2
23 à 7 à 0 0 c'est pas dramatique par
mon simplement 7000 rouge que vous dire
autour de cette table que ces trois
éducateurs non payées non mais attendez
de combat et parle de 200 euros par
éducateur mais non mais on peut passer
trois quarts ces trois personnes
s'ils toucheront pas trop le coup sûr
ses 7000 euros ces trois personnes
physiques et toucheront pas je parle pas
de drame puisque pour le coup je n'ai
pas fait la démonstration pour pour dire
que j'aimerais que les gens sachent que
le vote a un sens on ajouté on a voté
dans les communes et on a voté pour
cette caisse qui je veux qu'on sache
comment le vote ça sert à ça il ya
quelqu'un qui a été élue depuis il ya
des options qui sont prises je ne les
conteste même pas je vais plus loin
oui j'ai fait une remarque c'est à dire
que c'est la baisse des dotations de
l'état qui oblige sa et les
collectivités territoriales qui oblige
alors pour le mac et howie moi j'aime
moi j'étais là pour commenter ce que
j'avais entendu à l instant si faut
élargir on est bien d'accord on est bien
d'accord ça vient allez on va faire
plaisir c'est la gauche qui a fracassé
les collectivités locales et on essaye
de retrouver les marges de manoeuvre
c'est pour ça que j'ai bien parlé de
weill a pas d'argent
parler de compétences optionnelles qui
lève au moins il assume et c'est ça que
j'apprécie ce qu'ils assument elles pas
en parler simplement j'aurais préféré
qu'on fasse peut-être un peu autrement
mais qu'on regarde un peu les choses
différemment et l'habiller autre chose
que je voudrais dire c'est que sur le
plan national
finalement tout le monde rit tout le
monde dit il faut faire des économies
dans ce pays à chaque fois qu'on touche
à sa propre s'appropriant la labour ne
veut pas alors c'est en ça que je dis
ils ont pris leurs options et ils ont
levé il assume on en parle en revanche
au moins je ne le conteste pas plus que
ça si ce n'est de dire si c'est un
impact ne dit pas que ça n'a pas
d'impact
en revanche moi j'ai créé appel depuis
appel c'est quoi puisque on saupoudre
sur toutes les associations culturelles
et sportives appel va s'adresser à la
culture et au sport aux associations
culturelles sportives de la ville de
trappes
l'idée c'est de mutualiser cercle
finalement ce qu'on va perdre d'un côté
peut-être qu'on peut le retrouver avec
les moyens de mutualisation en gros je
vais travailler pour faire en sorte que
ces pertes la soit compensée par le
travail sur la personnalisation et
surtout on peut peut-être faire même
mieux qu'on ne faisait jusqu'à
maintenant parce qu'on va se parler on
va faire des choses ensemble
donc oui je sais
bien compris bardot c'est que ce que
vous regrettez un peu c'est que celle
soit 30% pour tout le monde s'en voit là
sans qu'on regarde exactement là où il
va peut-être regarder moins 30 pour tout
le monde
on l'apprend par les médias n'étaient
pas alerté de ce à un moment donné on
l'a su et c'était comme ça donc ya pas
cette concertation dont on peut
éventuellement imaginer qu'elle puisse
avoir lieu ont entre les cas par an
moins des relais et troisièmement où il
qu'elles soient sans descendant mais
encore une fois je l'acceptent je dis
simplement aux gens voilà les compos
menacé d'un vote
on a voté il faut savoir qu'il ya des
gens qui sont élus qui prennent des
décisions
ils prennent les décisions et les as une
bague ou des vosges au gosier sacre
était saoul a lancé le cas ce qui quand
elle avait déjà commencé à réduire
autour de 13 2 tours de traîneau pas
trimestre mais moi florence autret
complaisance mais non je pas en rajouter
je suis assez d'accord avec nous non
mais juste sur le plan culture je suis
assez d'accord avec sephora parce que la
culture je pense que c'est vraiment
quelque chose extrêmement important mais
il ya un grand tertre à 59,7 national
interest d'avoir trois quatre lieux où
on fait des choses qui sont déjà parfois
passés à saint quentin pour reprendre
ailleurs je pense pas que ça tourne tout
ce qui passe autour de 55 nous passons
pas dans les autres théâtres qui sont
sur 50 ans michael va drainer la
population tour mais dès qu'on s'éloigne
un peu sur l encours sur trèbes je suis
désolé je n'en ai jamais partons qui
savourait migration et dans l'amoureuse
rebbouh tout le monde mais je suis pas
certaine que le fait de deux fermiers xy
théâtre va renforcer l'implication d'un
casque et au niveau du service correct à
quel point c'était un facteur de
l'identification d'une ville nouvelle
cette identification je sais pas si elle
s'est fait vraiment parler culture
d'ailleurs mais fab au noumatrouff
c'est vrai qu'à 30 ans on peut se
demander si elle a besoin de dons de
sang mais sont peut-être de 50 ans et
c'est une vraie réussite un parce que le
travail qui est fait avec rap avec les
écoles et collèges
c'est une très grande réussite mais il
ya eu des moments difficiles hauteur de
50 ans des villes notamment sur des
budgets alloués par la part la caisse
king par la drac
il faudrait que soutenir peut-être un
peu plus se taire si on décide d'arrêter
de soutenir
ils ont d'autres les autres ça c'est
qu'ils vont annoncer la fin de tout est
dit mais j'ai en dernier c'est non non
non je vous écris mais c'est moi juste
voilà j'ai une grande tendresse pour
pour roland gâteau alors avec lequel je
suis un peu de temps en temps en contact
quittait donc l'ancien maire de guillon
l'ancien ralentir le président de la
caisse qui avant que ça s'appelle la
caisse président du sénat 58 de la
caisse qui est puis et progrès est prête
et créateurs la maison de cv et bah
ouais voilà c'est à lui que je pense et
je l'embrassé je pense que c'est lui il
avait lui même et cela dit voilà il ya
des questions de responsabilité
moussa fall a dit le responsable des
politiques qui sont posées il yad'un
côté
et budgétaires et d'écouter ces
équipements qui alors c'est vrai qu'ils
sont d'une densité relativement
importante saint quentin en yvelines par
rapport à beaucoup d'autres structures
urbaines de cette taille et puis de
l'autre la question de la pression
fiscale
donc j'ai pas il ya des choix opérés
mais alors alors on a l'impression que
ça tombe bien peut toujours sur les
mêmes
c'est vite en effet tout de suite la
culture le monde associatif etc
mais je sais la réflexion je me faisais
dans un premier temps mais dans un
second temps je me dis que finalement
non parce que ça tombe sur tout le monde
la situation dans les hôpitaux toutes
ces universités est une chose enfin bon
voilà mais c'est un peu oui il ya un
côté je rejoins moustafa un peut être
tranchée enfin au sabre ça me fait
penser à l'histoire d'un fonctionnaire
sur deux alors les non sens et c'est un
peu idiot c'est bien les dotations de
l'état qui sont moins aux collectivités
locales puissent se disent toutes les
collectivités locales elles vont pas
dire le contraire mais en réalité je
pense que c'est la conjonction de deux
phénomènes
c'est à dire que c'est en effet les
dotations de l'état qui se réduisent
mais c'est pas d'aujourd'hui et de
l'autre un train de vie peut-être bien
au delà des moyens des collectivités
territoriales elles mêmes qu'elles ont
dû à un moment ou un autre a su mais
alors très endettés les élus locaux vous
alors surtout les surtout les
communautés d'agglo qu'ils sont en
réalité les porteurs des dettes des
communes composant 10 des terres de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
mais les élus locaux vous dit c'est
parce que l'état se désengage que nous y
maintenir le pet dans les mêmes services
ont rendu doit mettre la main dans la
main à la poche
mais si vous regardez une inflation à
ces terribles des recrutements dans la
fonction lui il ya une depuis 82 alors
même déconnecté des compétences qu'ils
ont et n'ont cessé d'être conférer aux
collectivités locales
donc il ya une responsabilité à exercer
à prendre de la part des élus locaux eux
mêmes
ça c'est clair alors ils le font c'est
peut-être un peu discutable sur la
méthode mais ça va dans le sens le
sentiment qu'on a aussi au travers de
cette affaire c'est que c'est un
sentiment je peux me tromper bien
évidemment mais c'est qu'on a
l'impression que c'est une communauté
d'agglomération donc une communauté
finalement on met les choses en commun
et on donne le sentiment que chacun et
sur sa paroisse chacun a son pré carré
chaque commune veut ses équipements à la
fois sportif et ses équipements
culturels et finalement de communautaire
pour moi il reste j'ai l'impression
qu'ils ne reste pas grand chose et c'est
la raison pour laquelle j'insiste sur
cette idée que de créer une association
d'associations pour ce partage cette
mutualisation probablement qu'il y
aurait des choses à faire à ce niveau le
niveau de la communauté qu'on partage un
peu plus qu'on regarde un peu plus les
budgets et mutualisons peut-être un peu
plus ses premiers soutiens l'appel
puisque la longue ça sera lancé fin juin
alors la paix au revoir l'appel donc ce
sera celui du 16 juin parce que celui du
18 a été pris on lui rendra hommage mais
l'appel du 7 juin ont validé c'est une
association appelle association des
personnalités passionnées par
l'éducation et loisirs sachant que le
loisir est pour moi tout simplement un
prétexte pour l'éducation
sauf que nous on le dit on dit que le
loisir et loisirs la veille et on
applique donc ça sera le 16 juin ont
fait appel aux associations et aux
personnalités locales sur trappe pour le
moment et donc l'idée c'est de se parler
voilà je fais des choses sur le club de
foot on lance l'académie on lance des
tas d'initiatives au club de foot
j'aurais aimé faire partager par exemple
si les baisses de subventions
mutualisant des choses
s'il ya des baisses de subventions on
peut faire appel au privé c'est pas un
gros mot
c'est pas un gros mot que d'aller voir
des entreprises par exemple à la sncf la
ratp
la bnp par exemple je pense que je peux
faire des c'était 3 voilà donc trois 3
mai deux voilà il ya des entreprises qui
sont tout aussi citoyenne que des
individus qu'on puisse être donc il ya
des gens et qui ont fait appel et qui
regarde les dossiers sérieusement
probablement plus sérieusement que
certaines collectivités qui saupoudre
sans regarder à mon avis suffisamment en
revanche le mécénat lui a tendance à
regarder les choses de très près donc je
les invite à nous rejoindre à regarder
de très près ce qu'on fait mais je
voudrais également que ça profite à
d'autres associations do do la
plateforme
et puis surtout il ya un intérêt c'est
que si ces associations se parlent
pressé de faire des économies d'échelle
et faire en sorte que ça soit plus
productifs
l'idée c'est que si les enfants quittent
une structure quelqu'un de soins qui ne
se déstructure pas donc l'objet ça reste
une enfant
l'accompagnement surtout sur les
territoires comme comme trappe
mais très sincèrement sur tous les
territoires les enfants ont besoin
d'être accompagnés voilà l'idée de on en
perd lentement paradé merci à m ici même
un mot sur la réforme de l'enseignement
qui visiblement ne passe pas il ya des
grèves les graines de lausseignan
continue dans les associations de
parents d'élèves
il ya une présence notamment de la fcpe
qui avait soutenu la réforme qui était
obligée de démissionner alors il ya
peut-être une solution c'est de
remplacer des profs et il ya justement
un robot qui s'appelle un humanoïde il
s'appellerait now qui prend la place
d'un instituteur propose de regarder un
sujet on en parle tout de suite après
difficile à croire mais cette
interaction ce sont les enfants eux
mêmes qu'ils ont créé cette classe de
cm2 de la commanderie travail avec là
haut depuis le mois de mars
on va faire une correspondance avec my
pour apprendre l'anglais et on lan a
fait un programme mais sauf qu'on
faisait parler now en anglais ou en
français les les deux à la fois pour les
gestes on a tous fait de nous mêmes avec
des timeline c'est pour le faire bouger
nous-mêmes enfin pour par exemple levé
la main à droite cause la hausse et ce
petit robot humanoïde de 58 centimètres
de haut développé par une société
française
trois d'entre eux acheté par la commune
circule entre six groupes scolaires élan
courtois de la maternelle au lycée
près de 300 enfants sont concernés le
projet a été développé en partenariat
avec la direction académique numérique
et l'éducation nationale à travers
canopée le projet informatique dans les
écoles numériques dans les écoles pour
nous date depuis plus de dix ans est
donc l'aboutissement nous a semblé clair
il y a à peu près deux ans quand le
robot nao est sorti avec des
applications éducatif et ça nous a paru
évident de le mettre dans les écoles et
les collèges et les lycées du coup pour
permettre aux enfants d'acquérir les
compétences de codage informatique
on a voulu aussi donner envie aux
enfants de pouvoir avoir accès à ce
robot nao pour avoir plus d'enfants
qu'ils aient envie d'aller vers les
sections scientifiques côté notions
mathématiques programmation français
anglais mais pas seulement
ça leur a permis de vraiment de
comprendre que tout ce qui nous entoure
aujourd'hui ne fonctionnerait pas sans
la main de l'homme quand même puisque là
effectivement ils ont bien vu que pour
une seule
enfin une ou plusieurs questions ça leur
prenait quand même beaucoup beaucoup de
temps si on imagine pour tout ce qui est
autour de nous effectivement beaucoup de
travail j'aimerais encore plus avoir de
choses parce que je comprends pas tout
est d'être dans le métier avec mao on
peut aussi s'amuser
et le moins que l'on puisse dire c'est
qu'il a l'oeil
voilà alors c'était fade manceau est ce
que cette trêve ou être remplacé par un
robot pas moi il faut qu'on m'explique
que à ce moment là ce que je vais faire
alors je serais allé à la maison de la
poésie mais ça va fermer
je risque demande milliards mais enfin
bon c'est grotesque
enfin ridicule avec un r majuscule tout
sa fin il a sa place à versailles dans
leurs contemporains les sa valeur c'est
un bel objet ça on dirait les rebelles
bel objet voilà donc non non c'est
ridicule c'est dans cette grande
fumisterie consiste à dire que
maintenant l'école ça doit non pas
éduquer et instruire mais amusé alors
sûr que si c'est pour amuser les gamins
désoeuvrés huit heures par jour passé on
avait la tablette on a vu enfin ça fait
vraiment interactif en moins rare que
les profs les bruits voile alors c'est
peut-être le seul intérêt c'est que ça
fait pas grève mais c'est ridicule ça
c'est pas comme ça qu'on va apprendre
quoi que ce soit il ya peut-être un
intérêt en me fait que effectivement ces
humanoïdes c'est moins déshumanisée
voilà c'est pas trés c'est pas très
sympa je trouve si jamais qu'une
tablette sur pattes finalement d un
ordinateur donc un ordinateur il y fait
ce qu'on lui demande si c'est un
ordinateur sur bureau tablette ou sur
pattes
globalement il a une fonction
d'ordinateur il fera ce qu'on lui
demandera de faire
il ya peut-être qu'il ya peut-être une
fonction à laquelle on pourrait qu'on
pourrait imaginer ce qu on dit qu'il
faut plus de profs
j'adhère plutôt à st
dans certains au moins dans certains
quartiers dont certains territoires
peut-être qu'on pourrait imaginer que
pendant que le prof c'est pas pour les
supprimer c'est pour les aider pendant
que le prof
l'humanoïde en l'occurrence frais cours
à ceux qui suivent très bien voir ce
qu'ils vont plus vite les quadras pas
pour elle et il est l'imaginé faire son
truc dans son coin et que la prof ce qu
ils hésitent en main vous a inventé
l'école à trois vitesses et c'est
désormais bon allez vous aurez des profs
les vrais la dose est un vrai délire
vous rendez vous en défense à leurs
idées ils feront latin alan moore est ce
que la screen ce que nous aurons une
star hier signe à j ai trouvé un intérêt
visiblement n'a pas trouvé d'intérêt à
la locomotive à l'époque ni à l'avion
puisque tu décris la dame elle utilise
tous genres
alors c'est intéressant alors qu'il en
soit trop tard pour cette émission où on
découvre des talents
donc je continue maintenant c'est à deux
vitesses parce que quand la prof parle
elle parle pour tout le monde
il y en a qui décroche en l'occurrence
là on pourrait laisser des enfants avec
leur précieux et la prof fera en sorte
que les autres soient rattrapés rattrape
le groupe qui serait en difficulté
c'est au contraire pour que les vitesses
soirée en même temps que 200 m ils
peuvent servir d'éducateurs j'essaie
d'intégrer le règlement avant qu'il me
fasse ensemble en herbe au ballon que la
renommée tient de la croche un
aspirateur et en faisant des recherches
de prod et faire en sorte que les profs
me fasse que ce nous permet de jessey de
temps de reparler de votre invention
magnifique l'avion le plus long du monde
allume nous invite dans son tour du
monde il est bloqué quand même deux ou
trois jmen enfin je verrai le ramid il y
avait le tour du monde en 80 jours avec
jules verne et la 7e tour du monde
rapidement devenir le co maîtrise en
première les motive à charbon vers
l'élite eu le temps est là
vers des temps avant le tgv le motive à
charbon a subi tout autant de tracas ces
études sur le tgv aujourd'hui que demain
on prendra l'avion comme on prend
l'avion aujourd'hui sans une goutte de
pétrole faut bien qu'on commençait à un
moment donné cher ami qui pilotera la
jeunesse avait pris le premier la
demande et si les mecs quand conçu
l'avion ils ont pas un robot comme prof
remet en ce moment est la fille d'un
spectateur jeux de rang et la fifa est
ce qu'elle a un robot comme caen
pourrait pas parler aujourd'hui prendre
la place il ya maintenant parce que
cette blatter tout le monde déblatère
sur lui un platini tout le monde dit que
c'est un génie etc
et puis aussi le qatar est par exemple
tout le monde dit que le plus le pire
scandale c'est que le qatar organise la
coupe du monde de foot
or la coupe du monde de foot ya un type
qui était phuket et contre ses blatter
il met les textes latins dit reason
personnes
personne n'en parle c'est quand même ça
le brésil
oui parce qu'il est président du fn 4 a
parlé tout à l'heure parce que on
pourrait se demander si les tensions
géopolitiques steyer d'un côté les états
unis et l'europe qui veulent reprendre
en revanche et reprendre le pouvoir sur
le football face à l'afrique et aux pays
en crise appelé à voir notre foi ont été
défendues par blatter est simplement
juste avant de parler de ça est ce que
dans votre club on parle de ça de la
fifa ou est ce qu'on s'en fout
nous on parle que d'appel parce que la
peine c'est une suite sans arrêt sadaka
la monotonie blatter est favori ou bien
sa corruption à la presse qu est-ce que
vous que au football club de trappes
on s'en vont nous dire oh la la c'est de
cet ordre de mervans ou est ce qu'on
s'en fout complètement on s'en fout
complètement
encore une fois à chaque fois qu'on a
parlé de ce type d'événements chaque
fois je vous ai dit que c'était pas du
football pour moi pardon pour le coup
c'est une grosse machine une grosse
entreprise et ça reste à ce niveau là
mais là où jean charles à un raison
c'est pourquoi est ce qu'on parle de la
main de thierry henry aujourd'hui c'est
qu'il y ait des boules puantes qui vont
partir dans tous les sens en clair mme
platini qui a toutes ses vertus pour
prendre la fifa demain dit on on en sort
quand même dossier thierry henry donc
thierry henry veut dire la france la
france
à mon avis un maximum si ce n'est la
main de thierry henry au moins
éventuellement à vannes et mis un coup
de main à main de matinée donc on peut
imaginer que ce soit maintenant des
histoires de boules puantes
on voit là donc on n'en parle pas dans
son club dans le club parce que c'est
cette ce niveau on va juste te suivre en
espérant que tout ça fasse qu'on puisse
en tirer le meilleur
d'ailleurs j'ai un programme pour la
fifa si on voulait bien m'écouter un
jour dans ma démission
ce qui était intéressant quand et où la
main de thierry henry c'était de ce
qu'est vannes il faudrait rejouer le
match
taylor and run et chose et on s'était
fait et je on s'était fait attaquer par
des spécialistes de géopolitique
notamment brisé mais dedans
comment quant à matt every les jouer
l'arbitré assume enfin bon on s'aperçoit
même nom mais on s'aperçoit aujourd'hui
on s'aperçoit aujourd'hui quand même que
derrière tout ça il ya aussi un peu
d'argent oui mais ce que les
téléspectateurs ne savent probablement
pas pour l'avoir découvert de
l'intérieur sait qu'on a les mêmes au
sein du football amateur
c'est à dire qu'on a nos instances il ya
des commissions de discipline et des
commissions en général quittera titille
le dossier est vraiment n'est pas traité
à ce niveau là parce qu'il n'y a pas
d'argent il n'y a pas de transaction
mais c'est vrai qu'il ya des choses qui
sont réglés également en interne alors
c'est encore une fois sans argent et
sans corruption
là c'est un dossier qui a été traitée
par des avocats il est toujours en
action vous dépendez de la fédération
française de football
exemple de noël le graet tout était le
président de la faz assure france de
football qui lit partout que platini et
son ami mais qui a voté blatter est ce
que le président il se décide tout seul
mandat des gens de le conseiller
comment comment ça se passe le président
je pourrais pas répondre précisément la
question que je côtoie pas mis son
travail ni la personne mais globalement
nous élisons nous élisons dans nos
instances les sur le terrain on élit les
districts donc les départements des
départements la ligue donc l'île de
france par exemple les régions et la
ligue
elie donc président de la fédération
française de football sachant que dans
la fédération française de football il
ya le professionnels et les amateurs
donc c'est relativement clos au monde
amateur le monde professionnel nous
échappe complètement
c est ce qu on pense et je sais pas que
de toute façon c'est inhérent le
scandale qui n'est autre bol parce
qu'après tout c'est populaire de l'année
de l'argent est peut-être plus l'argent
puisque maintenant les très populaires
donc donc les marges moi je vais vous
parler de la main de thierry henry joue
à peine de ce dont il s'agit j'ai
quelques défenses des landes
comme il n'y pas pas je serais incapable
de recycler moi je me suis arrêté au
coup de boule de chemin cher de chez soi
r oui oui
donc voilà je crois que c'est le dernier
match de foot que j'ai regardé à la
télévision mais c'était pas réservé je
zappais enfin çà et là le la
télécommande n'existait d'ailleurs pas à
l'époque il fallait se lever pour la
paix donc voila tout ceci mais je
regarde ça là en spectateur pas amusé
mais comme une espèce de théâtre de
boulevard
enfin avec des portes qui claquent des
cadavres qui ressortent du fric partout
enfin voila c'est amusant de minutes
comptent autant que le match est sympa
mais je trouve ça c'est pas très
étonnant parce qu'on a vu le plein de
scandale le foot bon c'est vrai scandale
est que non seulement d'enjeux
financiers avec les dernières et les
annonceurs les partenaires et une
schizophrénie du de l'amateur de
football
enfin qui fait que et voilà il sait
qu'il ya des scandales il sait qu'un de
l'argent puisqu'il ya peut-être de la
corruption
mais si le match est bon il très
longtemps quand même d'abord réparer et
puis ensuite je vais te vois pas
florence qu'il nous rappelle sa mort il
ya quand même une certaine présomption
d'innocence
là tout le monde dit sont tous pour et
corrompu on sait pas qui est corrompu
qui est pourri qui ne s'annonçait pas du
tout là on balance comme ça
effectivement que dit moustafa des
boules puantes aux 10 cc c'est tous des
crevards c'est scandaleux cela non je
sais pas monsieur sécher à l'heure
actuelle j'ai lu beaucoup de choses sur
incapable de dire qui est vraiment le
type qui avait retiré de l'argent parce
que comme dans mon cas je ne sais pas on
apprend des choses actuellement elles
apprennent par exemple on dit voilà à
80,18 le maroc a versé des pots-de-vin
pour avoir le mondial sauf que c'est la
france qui lui est donc averti mon
affaire donc est ce que tout cela avec
les gens c'est toujours pots-de-vin qui
ne veut transformer ses patins
attaquer un petit quelque chose pour la
maison de la poésie sephora dont patrice
non c'est pour dire que sans parler des
personnes
clairement il y avait un système sauf
que le système tout le monde connaît le
système tout le monde le connaissait
donc il ya un système par exemple
effectivement quand il ya un problème
est qu'une nation il ya des transactions
par voie d'avocat par voie financière
quand il ya des choses qui vont pas bien
mais ça se règle entre eux il n'y a pas
de système de contrôle
il n'y a pas de voie là il n'y a pas de
c'est pas gérer comme avec une
gouvernance exceptionnel je crois que
c'est surtout ça sauf que tout le monde
en croque de ce système
alors après qui a pris plus que l'autre
ou qui a pris ou n'a pas prise à tout le
monde un désintérêt le système u
clairement connu deux fédérations en
fédération j'ai envie de dire que mais
là ça ressemble à lieux et fin qui veut
reprendre le football à son compte et à
mon avis sur tous les états unis qui se
veut déboulonner malaterre s'est pas la
victoire des réseaux ter de provence à
son groupe
en face et présente les 4 mais s'est
présenté comme ça ne s'est pas présenté
beaucoup comme ça on sait bien remplir
sa virée les corrompus mais c'est
peut-être aussi le système par
pour faire simple pour que l'été soit
horse comprennent c'est que chaque pays
et voit donc un pays ça peut être une
île
donc pourquoi tout le monde ce choc de
sarah justement la cible de l'onu
justement de tous les bas c'est parce
que c'est ce qu'on considère garde son
importance que la mienne c'est exact ça
va compter cinq autour de septembre etc
aux états unis à 300 millions
d'habitants et qui n'ont pas pu le voir
autant que les un peu partout il ya sauf
que ce système a été modifié justement
pour pouvoir donner une prééminence à
celui qui l'a mis en place parce que
finalement il avait d'ores et déjà mis
un système je dirais pas de corruption
d'achat mais il avait déjà mis un nombre
important pour le garder à vie contre
des blacks parce que finalement l'europe
s'est jamais qu'une trentaine de pays
les états unis lors de
du nord c'est trois quatre pays et
finalement il avait la prééminence de la
majorité par ce système dans ce système
notamment le cannet ça y est après la
victime avait les coopératives de presse
pour la distribution des journaux c'est
exactement le même principe c'est un
titre un petit train de thomassique et
de la corruption nous apprend que ça je
dis rien c'est ce qui est évident c'est
ce qui évite que les systèmes un petit
éditeur de presse à la même voie que le
groupe lagardère eh ben je trouve ça
très bien les gens le foot c'est pareil
je pas pourquoi les petits pays c'est
cdu c'est raciste parce que nous
trouverons un tel véhicule mais aurait
un achat je dis simplement que c'est le
système qui veut ça et tout le monde le
connaît mais les états unis qui pèsent
lourd en chiffre d'affaires en nombre de
personnes ont plutôt envie de faire
exploser ce type de système pour laisser
la pression ça l'europe et les états
unis
sephora là dessus non effectivement
alors on n'y a pas que dans le foot
c'est vrai a pas que dans le foot
maintenant le foot est l'un des sports
voir le sport qui draine le plus
d'argent que ce soit les transferts de
joueurs ou sont en jeu des sommes
colossales je crois que c'est dans ce
sport la clé les sportifs sont les mieux
payés le golf la boxe pas formule 1
alors que pour alors la formule 1 je
prends maintenant le foot je pense reste
devant ou pas loin donc effectivement
c'est là où il ya plus d'argent et j'ai
toujours entendu dire que dans le foot
tout s'achète aussi bien les joueurs que
les victoires donc nécessairement que
doit y avoir un peu de ça et puis comme
disait mustapha il ya forcément des
enjeux politiques derrière on soupçonne
plus ou moins mais qui existe certains
même un candidat aujourd'hui candidat à
l'élection dans son pays qui globalement
été financés par ce système
donc voila moi je ne peux pas laisser
dire de corruption comme calme à tous
on vérifiera facilement mais il ya un
basile boli non pas basile boli nanar
non non une personnalité de la fifa qui
était au conseil de l'exécutif de
mémoire et qui est maintenant candidat
dans son propre pays est dit on a touché
les fameux 10 millions d'euros qui
servira aujourd'hui à sa campagne donc
on va là on va ressortir tout ça c'est
pour dire si c'est juste pour confirmer
ou infirmer argent police domination
souvent l'un est parfait tout ça c'est
sorti comme ça tourne en cours qu'est-ce
qui a fait que déclencher des annonces a
demandé mais pourquoi les américains
parce que c'est une enquête qui est
parti vers mars ce serait bien ce serait
je crois serait que l'on sait que les
états unis voulaient la coupe du monde
2022 les états unis n'ont pas après
n'aurait pas apprécié et donc je dise un
verger à marchiennes probablement
probablement m
c'est ce que le qatar arrière de raison
de dire patient en attaque c'est plutôt
du racisme
tout le monde avait un petit manchot
quai des arts à puisse organiser une
coupe grey seulement passer les ismes
c'est un d'un mépris c'est scandaleux
que ce quoi vous quoi le qatar pourrait
pas jouer au foot aimer le foot et
organiser une coupe du monde de foot
aussi bien que n'importe qui va falloir
recevoir beaucoup de pays dans une telle
histoire qui avait prévu de france mof
un problème c'est juste que je veux
regarder chaleur de la gym que c'est le
quotidien là bas c'est à dire n ya pas
dix ans semble surtout n'ont qu'un
moment de la promotion du foot elle se
fait généralement pour donner un coup de
main aux pays acp qui accueille parce
qu'il ya des enfants j'étais agacé d'il
ya très peu aussi de le football quand
on connaît une très belle inconnue
n'avait juste pas ça qui joue donc ses
passagers
mais tant que les forces 1 que les
américains le boy's avez raison ils ont
raison les en raison de vouloir nous on
l'a voulu
c'est pas pour ça qu'on devrait dire non
vous êtes arabe et c'est là on est
d'accord d'accord mais c'est là où
finalement on en revient à une chose
très simple c'est que celle à l'offre et
la demande
tous les pays du monde veulent la coupe
du monde donc appartient moment-là veux
vexer tous les quatre ans il ya une
grosse prix à caen comptant les quatre
questions sur les 300 nationale n tout
doucement la vue de tous bords de la
coupe du monde de foot tour veut le tour
de france tout le monde les a bien sûr
c'est donc c'est des manifestations
absolument extraordinaire et
passionnante se fera à raison c'est là
le football est le sport qui draine le
plus de pognon
globalement en masse probablement
qu'individuellement les sportifs de
formule 1 ou 2 golf individuellement
peuvent toucher plus qu'un joueur de
foot mais globalement quand on regarde
le nombre de footballeurs las vegas qui
sont en moi c'est le fait voler on doit
être devant même super bowl devant même
le football américain
donc là il ya un vrai enjeu économique
donc qui dit économie dit de pouvoir et
de politique par définition tous les
quatre ans tout le monde la veut ça met
la pression à tout le monde
on est en train de parler de 2022 la et
will 26 et 2000 vont venir en russie
voilà ensuite on réussit donc les
américains qui n'ont pas vu passer la
coupe du monde chez eux la joie au qatar
et la joie ont eu ces alter la 94e peut
répondre aux états unis ils ont même un
nom déjà eu peut-être en mousse sur
l'extension de roland garros si ça vous
passionne
enfin sur les serres d'auteuil c'est
vrai que ça fait un gros débat les
écologistes étaient traict contre les
riverains sont très courtes rossi veut
le préserver ses serres d'auteuil et
manuel valls visiblement est passée un
peu en force contre l'avis de ségolène
royal d'ailleurs c'est avec le soutien
d'anne hidalgo c'est plutôt anne hidalgo
avec le soutien du dal go contre contrée
de noël c'est pas nouveau cela mais
c'est un peu scandaleux cette histoire
ce que vont vers tous roland garros est
très bien roland garros on voit pas du
tout le besoin absolu de d'augmenter sa
bon on pouvait couvrir le
l'autoroute c'était très bien et c'est
vrai que bousiller les serres d'auteuil
scandale absolu aucune raison que le
projet au dessus du périphérique est
formidable c'est moins de bruit moins de
truc c'était facile mais ça coûtait très
cher a coûté 270 millions je crois oui
enfin bon c'est encore une fois cette
saison on sent que ça va se passer si si
si ce n'est que c'est encore une fois il
y aura un investissement à faire à sa
charge à eux de savoir si un retour sur
investissement ça serait plus cher mais
probablement qu'il y en a un retour donc
finalement soit ça reste comme ça
soit on investit avec un retour mais on
peut pas se permettre effectivement de
mettre des subventions à mon avis des
collectivités locales pour faire un
projet qui serait en plus des structures
ans lorsque les serveurs mais au dessus
du périph si c'est plus cher qu'ils on
trouve là mais la manière dont un sur
six ont vraiment besoin d on va gagner
des sommes faramineuses hockey ce projet
c'est très endettés à jouer sous la
pluie mais non c'est vrai renouveau
centrale c'est vrai que ça boit ça
manque de place oui mais il paraît qu'au
delà de l'extension de roland garros
puissent être couverts si au cas où on
va dire c'est un poids movie blain mais
il était surtout aussi question de
moderniser les installations existantes
et que pour que roland garros puisse
rester faire partie des cinq tournois du
grand chelem c'était nécessaire sur
l'hécatombe
après moi je pense que roland garros
pour le coup ça fait partie des
événements temps forts français et
sportif alors pour une fois je pense que
s'il faut en passer par là il faut pas
être en opposition à chaque fois un
nouveau projet ça fait partie des temps
forts français il faut le faire oui mais
on s'en fout des serres d'auteuil santé
pour qui connaît des serres d'auteuil
les serres d'auteuil le tennis non
j'aime bien le tennis mais cela dit ça
me fait penser à ces têtes entre autres
juristes au sujet de ce qui s'était
passé au jardin d'acclimatation pour la
construction de la fondation dans vision
où on avait eu un contentieux
extrêmement intense long avec si vous
voulez une une intervention très
puissante de l'état qui avait en gros
changer les règles et qui les avait
adapté aux nécessités de la cause et on
a eu un peu cette même cette même
attitude
voilà quand le droit est un peu trop
gênant c'est pas grave on le modifie et
d'autant que la ville de paris avait été
à plusieurs reprises condamné en matière
de droit de l'urbanisme au jardin
d'acclimatation sur ce projet donc il
suffit de changer la loi pour pour s'y
retrouver alors il ya des comme ça des
sephora le disais c'est il ya des enjeux
politiques en même temps le droit ce
n'est qu'un outil
ça devrait pas être que ça temps en
temps mais au prix d'une
ils vendent tout ça et on refait la
marque roland garros à 50 ans maintenant
il ya un projet de le faire à versailles
notamment un gars de la marque et non
celle là il ya eu déjà un lieu désert un
débat et des candidatures est une idée
de 2 m euros l'aller retour de paris
elle a déjà été abordé l'étape elle a
probablement cette mutualisation
il nous reste à peine deux minutes un
mot peut-être le congrès du parti
grand spectacle
enfin le mauvais spectacle nous venons
enfin je m'apprêtais à dire le grand
guignol
non très mauvais spectacle mauvais dans
la mise en scène et l aller les deux vu
et du revu du nil et dur dit c'est
pathétique
mais bon ça fait partie du jeu
démocratique on va dire ça en faisant de
lui un sondage salariés plusieurs
sondages seuls par les analystes qui
montrent que pour 70% 75% des français
c'est un parti en crise ouverte entre le
saint siège et perspicace grave
enfin des deux côtés la politique en
général et est en crise et pour ça qu'il
faut remettre un peu de sens
notre ami madec n'est pas là aujourd'hui
mais il le dirait mieux que moi les
civils prendre sa place
ap elle fait partie de ce type de
rencontre a pour projet de renverser la
table on est contre rien du tout mais on
est pour l'a bien des initiatives mans
du contre personnes contre eux rien on
voudrait proposer et faire pour mes plus
jeunes et cordes et c'est vrai que c'est
vrai il pas besoin d'être grand clerc
pour dire que le parti soit en crise
c'est vrai mais c'est quand même assez
fascinant que les dirigeants de ces
partis ne n'ai pas l'impression que ça
il continue mais ils sont réversibles
la mène donc c'est une question de
renouvellement c'est toujours les mêmes
qui quelques mois je passe un tour de
magie des sujets sont liées aux
personnes
ce qui est important aussi c'est sous ce
qu'on oublie c'est que même si la
majorité des françaises semblent se
désintéresser tout ça les militants sont
pas complètement désintéressé il reste
des militants que ce soit à droite ou à
gauche qui eux sont intéressés par ce
peu par ces rassemblements par ces
congrès et c'est pour ça que valise mais
appréciant sa cavale ça va parce que
mais non mais le peu de militants qui
reste à droite comme à gauche
si tu les laisses tomber c'est une
catastrophe donc c'est normal que valls
que sarkozy qu'un calque que tout c'est
un politique se déplace dans des congrès
qui nous nous paraissent un peu désuet
voire ridicule c'est normal qu'il faut
pas humilier ni mépriser les militants
qui eux payent leur bail leur car c'est
son la ville les cajas même dans le sens
du poil mais les autres aucun intérêt
tout est bouclé jeudi les ca sans aucun
intérêt un militant du ps dernier mot il
est ravi quand même commune en france en
département une région en france en ait
en partie ses amis républicains sens
c'est vrai si par ses partisans
je pense qu'on a joué la dernière fois
sur la difficulté de renouveler la
classe politique et l'offre politique
merci à tous et des sacs